bonjour rentrée c'est vrai c'est à dire
que tu veux de tranquille ici non oui
oui y'a pas de tous les mecs viennent
pas de faire chier pour rien en même
temps censure m'asseoir ouais voilà
comment ça fait d'otages ces 5e étages
sis à 100 et 150 heures tu l'avais vue
sur la petite annonce à cantalous et le
tri pour wii ouais enfin c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est ma copine et puis je me
suis incrusté à la pâte les gaffes l
aube en même temps on est tranquille
quoi on a dû je suis sûr cieux on adore
vraiment un truc à dire quoi voulez
boire quelque chose je sais pas rivière
de l'acide relu cible ou du vin
de café
peut-être un café ouais je sache est
gentil merci merci beaucoup
ça va mieux ouais moi aussi
voilà où j'habite enfin je vais vous
montrer son orchestre
ouais enfin l'ag jamie qui sont là et
puis ma chambre là où je répète avec mon
orchestre de ma chambre
ouais c'est là que qu'on a commencé à
travailler à répéter c'est la même main
qu'on s'est connus parce que qu'on s'est
rencontrés parce que au départ moi jte
comme beaucoup de chanteurs je chantais
tout seul dans ma chambre avec mon
ordinateur tout ça ouais t'as commencé
comme ça je pars je m'embêtais quoi et
puis et c'est là que j'ai commencé à y
en a un des musiciens c'est mortimer
aspirateur il s'est présenté à moi quoi
il s'est mis à jouer spontanément sans
sens que j'ai rien demandé quoi
ouais alors j'étais un peu surpris on
n'a pas fait le boeuf tous et ça colle
et très vite quoi mais là vous jouez
toute la journée
non moi bon quand je joue avec eux un on
répète tout ça comme ça on fait faire
des concerts dans les bars tout ça puis
moi quand je suis pas là je leur laisse
la chambre et du moment qui arrange tout
bah ouais voilà alors ils font leur
petit truc tout ça aussi ils ont leur
formation particulier ils m'ont fait
d'ailleurs un arrangement geoffrey
écouter tout à l'heure un truc c'est
très actuel quoi ses plus jeunes tout ça
est ce que je peux vous montrer je
voulais
voilà ici assez parfait j'ai eu l'accord
effet je vous présente un voile amorti
meurt en l'aspirateur est loin derrière
derrière vous voilà on avait commencé
ah ouais quand on s'est connus alors on
a fait le buzz un peu
[Musique]
et alors il m'a présenté à ses collègues
musiciens il y avait les ont la boîte en
carton qui hélas non il est la super
vitesse
voilà là alors bon mireille le réveille
souvent et bien
donc tu vas être celle qui donne le
tempo général très très efficace je vous
ai fait écouter la l'essayer passé comme
ça parce que j'ai fait des
interconnexions avec d'autres pièces il
y avait mal bouffe le pommeau de douche
ah ouais ouais c'est il se connaît enfin
moi je ne savais pas ils se
connaissaient entre eux et moi j'ai bon
j'étais très surpris quand j'ai appris
que dans ma chambre il y avait tout ce
vivier de jeunes musiciens frais et
spontané tout ça alors g on a commencé à
discuter de ça je me suis demandé
comment comment il avait fait pour
pour en arriver là et c'est une école
quoi qui s'est formée dans ma chambre et
tout ça ça vient de deux professeurs
quoi de professeurs de 2
qu'ils auront un prix qui était dans ma
chambre je ne savais pas qu'ils avaient
tous acquis ce trafic est derrière moi
et notamment voilà c'est eux c'est des
objets qui sont musiciens depuis
l'enfance il ya un hic la guitare
électrique marushka l'harmonica mado la
radio ou escales et la lame à dos la
radio et puis et alors tout ça réuni par
le chef du pupitre qui est jennifer les
championnats oui voilà et ça fait quoi
là bas je vais vous je peux vous faire
écouter un un arrangement que ceux qui
m'ont fait j'aurais proposé une chanson
et ils m'ont écrit un truc en général
c'est moi qui ai écrit mais là et c'est
avec leurs petites formations donc c'est
assez frais quoi oui bah je vais vous
lancer sa préparé le petit chose je vous
m peut-être le costume de scène comme ça
sent mieux comme ça ouais
mais ça pourrait on a tu joues ouais je
ne mets pas en répétition ici je le mets
pas en général mais pour jouer la
chanson que je vais chanter accompagné
par le ccv ça s'appelle curriculum vitae
quoi
voilà
bon donc vain c'est jennifer
l'échantillonneur qui lance quand tu
veux je sais et chanteur je sais les
histoires qui font rire les filles je
les séduit jeu c'est mentir je sais
piloter
ça vient je reconnais les champignons je
sais maintenant je sais mentir je sais
piloter les avions en japonais je suis
une boîte pour les filles je peux
laisser moi je sème mentir je suis
intelligent mais ça ne se voit pas je
suis à pertinent mais on ne le sait pas
[Musique]
je dois le constater avec quel côté je
suis très érudit dans les îles gili
je suis allé ou ce day sans stop
je suis critique de musique pas je règle
l'épée
je connais les présentateurs j'ai mon
brevet de poésie je connais la
graphologie j'imite votre signature je
fais votre oeil
je connais la cuisine en jeu c'est là
sous sol en verre je suis fort je suis
très mal à je suis quelqu'un m'aide en
sait rien je suis intelligent mais ça ne
se voit pas je suis un pertinent mais on
ne le sait pas je dois le constater ci
dit je suis prêt j'ai lu dit dans les
yeux
je sais ce qu'est la ds3 je peux parler
d'une dérisoire la discipline diarrhée
fait que je la connais je la pratique un
jeu fait de la couture
je croyais pas
deux collections je sais danser avec les
filles
j'invente des chorégraphes je me suis
l'actualité
je donne des cours de karaté je
concourais tours de magie je connais les
super chaud je fais de la limite d'âge
je connais la médication gère aussi des
dons de voyance je vous prescris
désordre
je suis intelligent mais ça ne se voit
pas je suis un pertinent mais on ne sait
pas je dois constater que je suis est
rude dans les yeux je le dis je le dis
[Applaudissements]
bravo c'est magnifique
si t'as pas semblé c'est moi qui suit
ces magnifiques comme moi quand je suis
arrivé les cours est sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu